[Música]
inician las intervenciones de los jefes
de estado y de gobierno en la versión
número 75 de la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas con un foco evidente en
la pandemia la apertura como extradición
la dará el presidente brasileño jair
bolsonaro hay expectativa también por el
que podría ser el último discurso del
presidente de estadounidense donald
trump en esta plenaria tenemos reporte
desde nueva york
vuelven las restricciones al reino
unido- ante una segunda ola de kobe de
19 ministros boris johnson anunciará
ante la cámara de los comunes la serie
de nuevas medidas enfocadas en frenar el
contagio ya se adelantó que bares y
restaurantes cerraran a las 10 de la
noche de este jueves conectamos con
londres
y hubo jornada de paro nacional en
colombia los ciudadanos se manifestaron
contra la violencia policial la crisis
generada por la pandemia y también en
rechazo a las masacres y el asesinato de
líderes sociales que se dispararon en
comienza la mañana y también las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez buenos dias iniciamos el
informativo en nueva york eeuu donde se
ubica la sede de las naciones unidas hoy
comienzan los discursos virtuales de más
de 160 jefes de estado y de gobierno en
el marco de la asamblea general número
75 que da apertura a un nuevo período de
sesiones el gran protagonista es el
nuevo coronavirus para los detalles
vamos en directo a las calles
neoyorquinas con nuestra corresponsalía
mamen sala buen día para usted mamen y
qué podemos esperar hoy cuáles van a ser
los discursos más destacables
sin muy buenos días pues hoy vamos a ver
el arranque de esa asamblea general que
por primera vez es virtual en la que
normalmente se ha cuenta con la
asistencia de cerca de 2500 personas y
este año van a ser sólo 210 por esas
restricciones sanitarias arrancarán las
9 de la mañana como decías como es la
primera intervención del presidente de
brasileño
bolsonaro que viene siendo tradición
seguido del presidente del país
anfitrión en este caso el presidente de
donald trump se espera que donald tran
aproveche su turno de palabra virtual
para defender a todos los para atraer a
todos los votantes que puedan cuando
quedan menos de un mes y medio para que
se celebren estas elecciones
presidenciales así que hará hincapié en
su mano dura sobre venezuela y cuba en
un guiño a los votantes en florida hará
hincapié también en que este no es un
país socialista se espera también que en
un momento en el que precisamente el
multilateralismo lateral ismo es el tema
central de esta reunión de alto nivel
donald trump atacará de nuevo a la
organización mundial de la salud de la
que ya anunció la salida de eeuu de hace
dos meses y también a china al que
recordemos
de la expansión de el coronavirus por el
mundo también escucharemos al presidente
al dirigente iraní hassan de rowan y
quien se espera que se defienda en este
escenario mundial de esas sanciones
impuestas por eeuu que recordemos no
cuentan con el apoyo del consejo de
seguridad ni de el organismos y de las
naciones unidas también será el turno
ideal a mandatario chino quien se espera
que haga una apuesta incidente y te
apoye esa cooperación internacional para
luchar contra la pandemia hemos de decir
que ambos mandatarios tanto el ruso como
el de china es la primera vez que
aparecerán ante las naciones unidas
desde el 2015 luego por otro lado
también escucharemos al presidente
francés emmanuel al macro ni al
presidente colombiano que abogará que
remarcará el problema de la pandemia
gracias más o menos en eeuu continúa la
puja por la silla vacía que dejó en el
tribunal supremo el fallecimiento de
ruth báder ginsburg puesto que donald
trump espera llenar con una candidata
que anunciaría este viernes ozawa en
paralelo la sepultura de r&b
está prevista para el sábado y desde hoy
su ataúd está expuesto en la corte
suprema- donde los ciudadanos podrán
presentar sus respetos el posible
nombramiento es una oportunidad para los
republicanos que podrían inclinar la
balanza de la corte hacia el ala
conservadora con seis de nueve
magistrados en el senado el líder de la
mayoría del republicano mitch mcconnell
dice que se votará la nominada en
enfrentamiento con la bancada demócrata
cuyo líder chuck schumer dice que la
decisión debe tomarse cuando el país
tenga un nuevo presidente
si los colegas demócratas quieren decir
estar escandalizados pueden estarlo pero
ante la historia estadounidense
había un claro precedente para el
resultado predecible de lo que ocurrió
en 2016 y hay aún más evidencia
abrumadora para respaldar que el senado
vote este año
el pueblo religión nuestra mayoría en
2016 y la fortaleció en el 2018 porque
prometimos trabajar con el presidente en
los temas más críticos que enfrenta el
país doctor el sistema judicial federal
encabeza esa lista irónicamente fue el
líder demócrata de quien declaró en las
elecciones de medio término en 2018 que
las elecciones serían un referendo en el
manejo que el senado le dio a la corte
suprema
la mayoría republicana en el senado no
debería tener problema en adherirse al
último deseo de la jueza ginsburg el
líder mcconnell mantuvo una vacante
abierta en la corte suprema durante casi
un año para y cito darle una voz al
pueblo en la elección del juez de corte
suprema acabo de escuchar las palabras
del 10 republicano es obvio porque está
tan a la defensiva
y esto fue lo que el señor mcconnell
dijo en 2016 apenas horas después de la
muerte del juez es cali a el primer
equipo ser voice
el pueblo estadounidense debería tener
una voz en la elección de su próximo
juez en la corte suprema por ende está
vacancia no debería ser llenada hasta
que tengamos un nuevo presidente nada
puede cambiar lo que mcconnell dijo en
aquel entonces y esto aplica aún más
mucho más cuando estamos tan cerca de
una elección si pasamos el reino unido-
una información del cob y 19 porque el
país que ya superó los 400.000 contagios
y se acerca a las 42 mil muertes están
en la fase de alerta 4 en una escala de
5 según declaró del gobierno de boris
johnson
los funcionarios se reunieron hoy en un
comité de emergencia y el primer
ministro anunciará nuevas medidas de
bloqueo aunque ya se adelantó que bares
y restaurantes sólo podrán funcionar
hasta las 10 de la noche desde este
jueves en londres un saludo a marcela
gutiérrez corresponsal de france 24 buen
día para usted marcela y le pregunto qué
nos puede contar de las
ante esta segunda ola del virus
así es estamos a la espera del primer
ministro boris johnson se presente en el
parlamento de westminster en unos
minutos más así lo hará para anunciar
estas nuevas restricciones inevitables
ante esta nueva ola de contagios entre
otras cosas los focos tradicionales aquí
en inglaterra aquí en el reino unido-
restaurantes y bares se cerrarán a las
10 de la noche a partir de este jueves
esto con un intento de tratar de detener
los contagios que van en aumento día con
día además el gobierno recomienda a
todas las personas trabajar desde casa
quienes así lo puedan hacer excepción de
todos los trabajadores clave como
médicos y enfermeras que deben ir a los
hospitales son los maestros que deben ir
a las escuelas pero oficinistas deberán
hacerlo desde casa esto a pesar de que
hace unas semanas el gobierno estaba
recomendando a la población a quienes
así pudieran regresar a sus oficinas
también es importante destacar que los
jefes médico y científico del gobierno
patrick balance y cris güity
advirtieron el día de ayer en una
conferencia de prensa que van en aumento
los contagios y que a mediados de
octubre podríamos ver 50.000 nuevos
casos
boris johnson dará un mensaje a la
nación este día a las 8 de la noche hora
local gracias a usted la extrema derecha
e italiana admitió su derrota tras una
feroz batalla en las elecciones
regionales del país las miradas estaban
puestos en la región de la toscana
tradicionalmente de izquierda y es que
aunque se predijo que podría caer en
manos de la extrema derecha el partido
democrático del país de la coalición
nacional gobernante se las arregló para
mantener la veamos
la toscana de la extrema derecha ha
estado apuntando a hacer un borrón y
cuenta nueva pero no fue así el
tradicional bastión de la izquierda la
toscana habría sido el máximo premio
pero un recuento parcial de los votos yo
al candidato del partido democrático una
cómoda ventaja sobre su rival de la liga
matteo salvini habló sin embargo de
progreso que cuando cuando empezamos a
pensar en las elecciones en la toscana
hace unos meses algunos de sus colegas
nos preguntaban por qué estábamos
entrando a competir cuando estábamos 15
o 20 puntos por detrás de la izquierda
perdimos eso está claro pero estoy
contento porque estoy seguro de que
muchos de ese 40 por ciento que nos votó
solía votar por la izquierda
jurisdicción está
la liga se mantuvo en las regiones de
benneteau y lujuria mientras que otro
partido de extrema derecha los hermanos
de italia parte de una coalición
liderada por la liga de salvini le
arrebató le marqué al partido del primer
ministro y giuseppe conte el centro
gobernante dejó la coalición mientras
tanto se mantuvo en cuatro regiones
incluyendo la toscana
nicola zingaretti el líder del partido
democrático se sintió claramente
aliviado no es llamó muerto moltó
satisface y estamos muy muy satisfechos
esta es una confirmación de que el
partido democrático es una fuerza del
cambio en la fuerza del campamento los
expertos habían advertido que una
victoria para la extrema derecha habría
sido catastrófica para la frágil
coalición nacional de gobierno de
izquierda liderada por el primer
ministro y giuseppe conté estos
resultados son exactamente lo que la
izquierda había estado esperando
en américa latina colombia vivió una
jornada de paro nacional en varias
ciudades del país los manifestantes se
protestaron contra la brutalidad
policial tras la muerte del ciudadano
javier ordóñez el pasado 9 de septiembre
también rechazaron la crisis por kobe 19
y el recrudecimiento de la violencia con
masacres y asesinatos de líderes
sociales en un récord durante el
gobierno de iván duque el reporte lo
hace nuestro periodista luís muñoz que
cubrió las movilizaciones así está la
céntrica plaza bolívar de bogotá en este
21 de septiembre donde colombia tanto en
bogotá como en otras ciudades del país
han vivido una caravana social por la
vida y la paz uno de los principales
motivos ha sido la violencia policial
después de que hace dos semanas no hay
el 10 de septiembre muriesen 13 personas
por fuego real de la policía que
protestaban por la brutalidad policial
del día anterior de la muerte de javier
ordóñez a manos de varios policías dos
de los cuales han sido ingresados en
prisión vamos a escuchar a este
manifestante a ver qué nos cuenta porque
se está celebrando esta caravana social
el 21 de septiembre y la verdad yo
preste el servicio militar aquí en
colombia
soldado fusileros y mi hermano pues lo
que uno le enseñan uno toda la vida que
es defender a la patria al pueblo estos
policías como han hechos atropellos
escuchas no les tiembla la mano ni les
tembló la mano la semana pasada en
utilizar armas de fuego contra civiles
contra jóvenes pero además de la
violencia policial los sindicatos han
marchado convocados por el comité
nacional de paro desde primera hora de
la mañana para protestar contra los
efectos que ha causado el coronavirus
emmy generando una crisis social
sanitaria y económica que ha sacado a
relucir según los sindicatos los
problemas que vive colombia vamos a
escuchar al presidente de la
confederación general del trabajo la la
pandemia colocó al descubierto todas las
debilidades de un sistema capitalista
que fracasó estruendosamente en colombia
y nosotros ya veníamos con la tasa de
desempleo la segunda más alta de américa
latina uno de los países más desiguales
del planeta
antes de la pandemia la pandemia que lo
que se coloca en la superficie toda esa
problemática está por ver cómo continúa
este 21 de septiembre la situación
social cuando los movimientos sociales
esperan que se recupere esa ola de
indignación del pasado 2019 cuando el 21
de noviembre un paro nacional convocó a
miles de personas que terminaron con
promesas políticas por parte del
gobierno de reformas que aseguran los
manifestantes de este 21 de septiembre
que todavía no se han cumplido
y en australia hay una carrera
contrareloj para rescatar a casi 300
ballenas piloto varadas frente a la
costa de tasmania muchos de los animales
murieron y los rescatistas hacen todo lo
posible para salvar a los que quedan
un panorama tan extraordinario como
perturbador 270 ballenas piloto un tipo
delfín oceánico atrapadas en bancos de
arena elevados frente a la costa
occidental de tasmania intentar rescatar
las es una tarea titánica el gerente del
servicio de parques y vida silvestre del
estado explica que la prueba y error es
el único método posible para proceder
es en gran medida un proceso de tratar
de encontrar el mejor método así que
intentaremos liberar algunas ballenas
esta mañana y si tenemos éxito con el
método que hemos elegido seguiremos
haciéndolo si no lo adaptaremos y
haremos diferentes cosas para intentar
obtener un mejor resultado
nadie sabe que atrajo los animales tan
cerca de la orilla se cree que al menos
un tercio de ellas han muerto la
prioridad ahora de centrarse en los que
tienen más probabilidades de sobrevivir
y el triage va a ser bastante importante
aquí tenemos animales repartidos en un
área grande y en una ubicación realmente
desafiante así que básicamente vamos a
tomar a los animales con la mejor
oportunidad para empezar y los que somos
capaces de tratar algunos de wiss los
encallamientos de ballenas aquí no son
inusuales pero la escala de este silo es
en tasmania el último a escala masiva se
registró en 2009 e involucró a unas 200
ballenas las autoridades dicen que la
operación de rescate podría demorar
varios días
hasta aquí el informativo pero ya
volvemos con más siga con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]